one of the surprises from tonight's game
awards has been revealed early a youtube
video that went up today but has since
been taken down reveals that the four
fighters in Mortal Kombat X is combat
packed to our Leatherface from Texas
Chainsaw Massacre xenomorph from alien
foe ride show a drunken fist master in
tri Borg a combination of Cyrax sector
and robot smoke these four characters
will be released in the first quarter of
2016 pricing was not announced with the
first Mortal Kombat packs sold for
thirty dollars Mortal Kombat X was
originally released in April 2015 for
xbox one playstation 4 and pc dlc
characters released so far have included
Jason Voorhees predator tanya and tremor
it looks like you'll finally be able to
host your very own alien vs predator
battles that will undoubtedly be better
and probably gory ER than both of the
film's the full reveal video will be
shown tonight at the video game awards
and you'll be able to find it and more
mortal kombat info on gamespot com